all
right all right welcome to the ddps
seminar everyone before we introduce our
invited speaker let's go over some rules
and Logistics uh first of all please
mute yourself during the talk but if you
have questions you can unmute and ask
questions or use chat room to post your
questions so that we can address them in
Q&A session at the end second today's
ddps seminar is open to external
audiences uh therefore no classifi
discussion is allowed so please watch
out finally The Talk today will be
recorded and uploaded in our YouTube
channel that's about it now let me
briefly introduce our speaker today it
is an honor to Dr Francesco rmer who is
a post-doctoral researcher in the
numerical mathematics and scientific
Compu group Computing group at the uh
visor trust Institute for applied
analysis and stoas um stochastics in
Berlin Germany he received his PhD in
20123 in mathematical analysis modeling
and applications from the International
School of Advance studies in triesta
Italy is this is supervised by uh
Professor Gian Lugi Rosa and Professor
Giovani stabel focused on the nonlinear
parameter space and model order
reductions enhanced by scientific
machine learning today franccesco will
talk about intrusive model order
reduction of parametric pdes using
neural networks approachment of the
solution manifold and adaptive hyper
reductions I'm sure we are going to hear
a wonderful talk from Francisco now let
me ask a question to Francisco just to
get to know him better uh
there you
go okay I happen to know that you are
passionate about
dancing yeah what kind of dancing do you
like to do and if you can describe uh
what it is and how it how you how it
works briefly that would be awesome okay
uh well it started years ago even before
Co to dance uh Lindy Hop also here in
Europe and uh yeah it's it's a very
lovely environment and a way to distan
yourself from coding and math let's say
it's more Focus work job and yeah I
guess everybody knows at least what uh
what Lindy Hop is but yeah I guess it's
well
yeah but yeah I mean I I suggest you to
look into it into YouTube I don't know
or yeah I will so definitely yes yes you
increased my curiosity about that great
the stage is
yours thank you uh thank you for the
introduction and so I will uh present a
work I've done during my PhD studies at
cisa uh in collaboration with joanni
stabil and joh Luigi rotza uh the work
is about an extension of the hyper
uction of the N manifold method and
before introducing it I will present
some motivations behind the new
methodology so uh introduce theone
method starting from the fin element
passing uh through the reduced basis
method so if you have in mind the uh
most simple PD like the Bon uh problem
you can write the we formulation in this
way and you can discretize it in space
and choose your uh dis disc isation
method of choice for example the INF
method um in this case your anet space
would be the space of continuous
functions that are restricted locally to
the elements of the triangulation are
polinomial of degree K but you could
also choose a a spectral goal basis of
Aon normal functions on the world domain
if domain is
nice and but what about if you have
additional parameters uh on your pdb for
which you have to find Solutions and
these parameters may affect the um
geometry of the of your computational
domain or enter as diffusion parameters
in your week formulation or in your
Source term uh well in this case uh you
could exploit some solution you have
computed before beforehand in a so
called training stage um to tailor a
specific answer space for this problem
to infer new Solutions corresponding to
parameters you have not seen yet and
this is a lot uh very as many
relationship with the uh using this
spectral Bas uh method on the world
domain uh instead in this case we would
use a much smaller dimensionality uh
reduced bases so still linear bases but
tailored for your uh problem
so this is more or less the nomenclature
of model redution so you want find to
find solution uh for this wig
formulation and you introduce a
parameter space k to which your
parameter Mo belongs to uh the solution
map L from the that keepes uh that Maps
each parameter to solution the solution
manifold which is the image of the
parameter space through the solution map
and in a training stage usually collect
it's called Snap Matrix so for different
parametric instances from one to n train
uh the respective
Solutions once you've done this uh you
consider the same uh weak formulation
but instead as answer space you want to
find your solution as linear combination
of a few number of mods let's say r with
r very small with respect to the full
dimensionality of your state
space and this uh this linear
combination is made with a vector on the
global basically in relation also in
with a lot of analogies with a spectral
um uh basis method on the B domain but
in this case the um elements of your
basis will come from a singular value de
composition of your stion
metrix and of course the idea behind
modular reduction is that you amortize
the cost of computing addition
additional and um training snapshot uh
in order to per uh to infer efficiently
new solution at the prediction or online
stage
um so uh but of course this sometimes is
not sufficient to approximate accurately
uh a solution because um in model
reduction you usually you sacrifice uh
accuracy in term and in favor of uh
comput slow um a smaller computational
cost um but in some cases this is not
enough and you need uh approximate which
are not linear in a sense so I will
present today how you can use as answer
space uh nonlinear mappings so a linear
answer space for your solution and how
you can Sol for resolution in an
efficient way uh in this case for
example you can consider as answer space
the image through a Nar map Fe instead
of a lar map from an open Set uh in the
amb space of dimensionality r with r
still uh very smaller with respect to
the full dimensionality of your state
space and uh of course the problems of
using uh a linear reduced basis uh is
very well known in the researcher and
can be explained simply with looking at
the the reduction of a scal transport
problem so in this case the ini
condition is zero and you have boundary
condition equal to one so basically the
solution if you consider standard
isation is one followed by zeros so it
discontinous and at the next uh time
instant will be one one followed by Zer
one one one followed by zero if you
assemble the snapshot Matrix uh where
the columns correspond to your Solutions
at different time instances in this case
time is the only parameter and then you
evaluate uh the um igen modes with the
SVD um you can then plot the residual
energy of your system and you can see
that even with different levels of this
cation from more or less 100 to 2,000
you can see that you need more than the
80% of your modes to uh retain more than
95% of your of the energy of the system
um this in comparison uh to for example
the incompressible those equations so a
typical Benchmark flow P the cylinder
and implemented in the in the caed
volume inside the open pH and you would
see that you would need less than uh
five uh% of the of your uh I function of
I modes to retain more than 95% of the
energy of the W system so even if it's a
more complex problem to solve um the
it's more easy in this in to to reduce
with the reduced bases method in this
sense and a lot of practical
applications have this problem and to be
more quantitative uh it's the concept of
comar and WID is introduced so uh you
consider a parameter space k uh Sub sub
Compass set of a parameter space
caligraphic p and you can def find the
col and width for as for a fixed
dimensionality and of your L
approximation space as the best
approximation error uh uniform with
respect to the solution manifer
and the com WID has been evaluated for
it's Astic has been evaluated in many
studies and you can see that even for
the incomplex equations using
considering as parameter the source term
itself as a function you have almost you
have exponential decay One n
one one divided by three times some
constants and also the famous case for
linear cive problems of exponential
decay but also uh more difficult to
prove for solution map which are
allomorphic uh you can find
the approximations Astic estimates like
this so for a for a parameter Mo which
is a function of regularity s uh you
have this kind of estimates and of
course uh for the linear action problem
I presented before but also wave
equation you would have instead a lower
uh bound of n to the minus one Al uh
this stly depends also on the initial
conditions so uh it's important to
notice that not every advac Dominator
problem has this kind of comogo slow
comogo with Decay uh in fact a lot
depends on the regularity of the initial
conditions and also on the lity of the
parameter to solution map and more
generally also it's um it may happen
that in Practical applications even if
you have a atically local M with DEC you
may still reach uh a sufficient accuracy
with the sufficient sufficiently small
number of modes so it does not mean that
if you have a very slow com DEC then you
cannot approximate your problem at all
it depends uh Case by
case um yeah and also as I said not U
this Pro this problem of loc with the K
affects not only adduction Domin
problems uh but a lot of applications uh
like for
example problems with the
parameterization that change the
computational domain or more complex
models with complex Dynamics and smaller
scales in your Dynamics Etc so a lot of
in the literature these are some um
references some methodologies uh which
uh researchers have triy to um solve
this problem so uh and some of them are
can grouped as uh local methodologies
like the M composition or interpolation
on the space of parameters uh some
others uh take Inspirations from uh
machine learning uh linear Dimension
reduction techniques like can based
methods uh some others from Imaging
Sciences like old techniques like
registration uh apply for example in
2014 for registering U
geometries and more recently um also out
encoders so in the last serence of lean
carber and today I'm going to talk about
an extension of their
methodology um with um hper reduction
so uh autum coders um have been uh
spread uh also in the model reduction
community and S modeling Community also
uh thanks to the Advent of uh resnet and
CNN from the 2010 to 2015 16 and also
with
the with the development of Open Source
software like pyto tlow available for
everybody and especially these are some
of the first works I I managed fun on um
um out encoder CNN used as purely that
driven methods in computation of
Dynamics um so a lot of techniques also
nowadays are structured like this in um
so they are P even RS and they have uh
the task of Sur model is divided in two
steps let's say even if sometimes they
perform at the same time so the first
step is to approximate the solution
manifold and so the basically
architecture you have is an not encoder
uh so with a an encoder map uh C from
the full State Dimension to reduc lat
Dimension R and the recorder M and the
recorder map from the reduce lat
Dimension R to the full State D um and
then you have another neure that um how
job is to uh infer and to learn the lat
dynamics of your uh system so if you
plug in different parameters um for
example also time and you produce the
solution but inside this smaller latent
space of course in there are many
examples and which the architecture
changes so for example you can use uh
for the solution manifold learning
problem convolution encoder variation of
encoders uh Gans out encoders lsdm out
incoder chnn bod there are many AR
available right now and also for the lat
you can use gion process regression f
for Network lstm C convolutional
networks n there are many
Alternatives um but these are only P
data driven methods this means that
there isn't a training stage and a
predictive phase but in the predictive
phase you only uh plug in your um inputs
your parameters so for example time and
other parameters of your param tpd and
get the solution um instead uh what you
want you to do is to preserve in a sense
uh the physics so instead of um of using
this Paradigm we wanted to uh find the
solution also at the line stage in a
sense solving um uh keeping um keeping
in mind the numerical schem using the
full order model so for example
minimizing uh first principles and this
is something that you cannot do with
standard uh that driven uh ROMs that
discard completely the physic in the
physics in the predictive
phase uh so the original work introduced
by uh lean
carbug um is uh can be presented like
this so so you first extize your paramet
PD in space and you obtain n o so in
this case uh you represent your state
variables so you so the physical FEI can
be stuck together for example for in
compressible stes equations you would
have a velocity pressure and you would
then obtain an o n o system where f is
your vector field and can be also linear
depending on your RBD and of course the
initial condition and you can discretize
it in time uh and it is you have a
residual that depends on the parameter
of course but also on the uh time
instant you are solving for the for the
solution and also the previous uh time
instance instances belongs belonging to
the interval
it and the isation of theal condition uh
for example for the um implicit Oiler
method you would have a formulation of
the residual uh like this
one so this is um the boxes uh compare
the uh list Square part of gy method uh
it's an application of the the spases
with the linear manif SPG and you can
see the differ is uh on the choice of
answer space so on the Le square of gy
method you start from a latent a reduc
coordinate z z z uh that you obtain
after linear projection of your uh
initial condition u z and this uh you
this PR Matrix is just uh The Matrix
whose column are the uh I modes of your
SVD for example uh of your snapshot
Matrix so what you do next is uh if you
have time parameter you consider you
have to find the solution at the next
time step solving this uh Le Square
problems minimizing the residual and in
this case instead of the state utth you
plug in the Reconstruction from the lat
variables PR set of course if your uh PD
has an a find the composition with
respect to the parameters you can uh uh
save the redu matrices offline and the
procedure will be um efficient but if
your C for example is nonlinear then you
would need to apply a protection
techniques to make it U to make this
solving this problem independent from
the number of degrees of freedom so on
the right side instead uh you see that
using uh encoder and decoder so linear
Maps is easy as just plugging in them
inside the position of the State uh you
would would be considered before and so
now to find the initial reduced variable
you would use the encoder and encode the
initial um conditions and then you would
evolve the dynamic in the latent space
always with a small dimensionality R but
in this case the state will be
reconstructed from the ltin space to the
full State space through the decoder
fee and so this is the formulation if
you want to think about it uh
graphically you have on the left on the
left side a plane which is our uh Vector
Space spaned by the IG modes of SVD
approximates this kind of nonlinear
manifold uh while you can see that
Dynamics is evolved in the latent space
and all in the end reconstructed on the
solution manifold while on the right you
want to try to approximate Your solution
manifold with a nonlinear proximum map
so in the end you will also have a
linear approximation of your of your
solution manifold of course now if your
residual is uh in the beginning linear
you introduce nonlinear map so you need
to solve a nonlinearly square problem if
you you see the n linear you it would
still be n linear but you add an
additional nonlinearity coming from the
decoder and there are many methodologies
uh that can be used to optimization
algorithms can be used to solve the
linear sare problem among them uh quas
Newton methods uh and also other
variance like Pounders implemented in
Psy that we that is what we use for The
Benchmark I present today but also the
Lark algorithm test is for other
benchmarks in other references uh from
the inside the igen Library
um of course the problem is that as in
the original implementation of thean
carberg you still have a dependency on
the full dimensionality of your uh State
space and so even with this formulation
it may happen that your uh do model is
even uh more inefficient than your full
order model so you need to apply some
sort of hyper reduction and of course
the full
dimensionality um I mean the residual
has full dimensionality but also the
state space and the one of the simplest
approaches is to use over collocation
method so you define a matri with Matrix
which restricts the residual only on
some uh collocation notes and of course
if you consider standard methods like DG
fam or F volumes then if you want to
evaluate the residual locally on single
noes you would need just a stencil uh
around them for because the differential
operators um of your disc of your disc
isation are defined only locally um of
course this map so uh pass inside the
the residual definition and you what you
just need to do is restrict the um
reconstructed State space only on this
submesh
PSR and the end so you can restrict the
residual uh GT only in the collocation
nodes and the output of the decoder only
on the submesh of course there are uh
many other implementation of production
uh there is there there is dime there is
EC s SW there is gnat there is also s
opt which improve the point selection
algorithm and um yeah but of course um I
will show maybe some examples of the
these submeshes if you the first time
you've seen it so in red you see the
collocation notes so only the notes in
which the res is evaluated and in blue
in light blue the uh nodes the cells
that are you that uh make make that make
part of the subash so on this two gits
orthogonal GDs uh come from two
benchmarks that I've used in another um
um experiment I introduce it later maybe
and but you can see that this is a
nonlinear conservation L problem with
the with the parameters also time so you
can see a moving front from the uh left
bottom corner to the right top corner
and this is the shallow water equation
should the solution should have a radial
uh symmetry uh but you can see that uh
the subesh size depends on the numerical
scheme rosing so for example you could
have only one layer around each single
node of your residual or more layers
around
them uh but of course the problem is
that now you use a decoder uh which in
general may be a very big map and so you
need to find also uh ways to or Define
uh shallow or thin architectures that
are at the same time shallow and so
efficient to evaluate many times and
accurate or you can uh you have to find
other techniques to solve this
problem so these are the references I
could find above about extensions of the
Nar manifold method and all of them use
hyper reduction in a way so the first
reference was of course by Kim
youngia but they used the shallow masc
out encoders we tried in we attempted to
use um compon short decoder and then um
approximate the decoder uh with uh with
a smaller one in a second side with
teacher student
training um so it's a parad machine
learning to train smaller NS from uh
bigger models let's say h so that it
could we could have an an efficient
small network to use in our nonlinear
pration to solve the N linear Square
problem but there are also other
approaches in the to consider for
example outen cers between sub meshes of
Viper reduction or uh that split the
your approximate in a linear part and
the linear part but obtain also
composition within a linear part uh made
of an N Network or an approach that I'm
going to present uh today uh and also of
course uh approaches they consider part
partitioning approaches so domain the
composition in each the the composition
of a domain you consider a new encoder
and perform in this way um hper
production and so the approach I'm going
to talk about today is the following it
relies a lot on the a technique very uh
was spreading machine learning which is
um it's considered using SVD as per
processing step to extract minone
features from your database uh for
example if you have in mind the the
diffusion processes and um stable
diffusion so uh sorry diffusion model
and stable diffusion so what you do in
Asing step you um extract and reduce the
dimensionality of your uh image let's
say usually with other architectures but
you also or in this case we use SVD or
generally I called the filtering
transform map and with this same mean uh
random parallel randomized SBT which is
very efficient for very big problems on
mches of more than one million degrees
of freedom uh but you can also consider
a fast for transform or other
Transformer of your
choice um so the architecture is instead
in this case done is as the structure so
you first have uh linear layer uh that
consider let's say a matrix with columns
the ion modes of your transform map for
example the a modes of randomized SVD
and that projects your state space from
D to a dimensionality p the
dimensionality of the frequency space
let called it and then from you want to
reconstruct this frequency space with a
small outo encoder made of fit forward
nural networks or 1D CNN and so this
encoder Maps this frequency space spe to
reduce lat anation R and then
reconstruct it back with flda at decoder
from R to B where B is much smaller than
D so B is the is would be the number of
your reduced basis modes for example and
but in with respect to reduced bases
applications this P can be much higher
so usually for reduc spaces can be less
than 50 modes let's say uh in our
application spe is equal to
300 uh because it achieves an accuracy
in a very efficient way with randomiz VD
in this way regarding the Reconstruction
error and finally we have linear
projection from P to the full State
space d
dimensionality of course if you consider
um U as a field uh you consider many
fields stuck together and you can we
applied monolithic SVD and you of course
have to renormalize the fields because
you may have pressure and velocity or
other fields and so you need to apply a
weight that uh let's say make it uh this
state space independent from the unit of
measure and of the uh on the on the
physical quantity you are considering
let's say uh this way you you obtain a
more accurate reconstruction error
considering only randomized spe uh so
now you have uh let's repeat a very
small and fast and Fast to evaluate the
coder from R to P because it's just from
the latent space to the uh frequency
space uh so the space of that you obtain
projecting the the your snapshot and
then you have a linear projection uh F
minus one filter uh from this frequency
space p to the full dimensionality and
why this uh choice of Architecture is
very useful for our applications because
then you can apply hyper production very
efficiently because you have a very fast
Network to evaluate and
then uh you have you can if you want to
apply a production and you have selected
as a mesh and what you need to do is
just restrict the uh rows which
represent the dos
uh of the the of your of your of your
system uh you can just erase them if if
they do not belong to your submesh and
what you uh find then is just this
nonlinear approximate composed by a
nonlinear part which is the same the the
coder part of the encoder and then a
much smaller uh linear map from the
frequency space p to the Restriction of
your modes uh to the submesh you're
considering with with your r reduction
technique in our case uh the over
collocation method so in this way you
you have found a an accurate uh in some
cases when uh randomiz SVD um achieves a
good reconstruction error using also a
lot of modes like 300 modes uh but also
uh thin because you have just you
restrict the linear map which is the
which is the biggest part of your
network uh only to of your map of of
your full of your of your allog together
n map only to the
submesh and we wanted to take a step
further and we wanted to also try an
Adaptive strategy since when you
consider at production sometimes if you
have a fixed mesh uh but then uh the
major components of the of your residual
moves during the evolution of the
Dynamics so you may want to follow these
uh features of the Dynamics uh with your
magic points and so uh one two one way
to do this uh consider also that we have
a map that uses in our network is The
Following so you first Define a map from
Z which are your latent variables uh to
theable state space so that is mapped uh
to reconstruct the state space with the
fee which I want to remk is made by a c
f uh which is a nonlinear part and then
a linear part and then this is plugged
in into the residual evaluation and that
has the full dimensionality of your
state space so then you want to compute
sensitivities so it's simple chain rule
you see that there is a component that
is um the derivative of the with respect
to the state a component it's linear
with respect to the reconstruction with
linear construction you're employing and
then a component which is the jobian of
the output of your restricted decoder of
your sorry small nonlinear decoder
respect to the latent uh variables so in
the end uh
evaluate the sensitivities for the
choice of magic points would be too much
expensive and so we decided instead to
use this kind of indicator so you we cut
off of this part and we consider only
this part here uh which instead
considers only the Reconstruction filter
and uh the previous latent um latent
coordinates to evaluate the Jacobian of
fetier and so in this way uh you have a
map which is more efficient to
but as the dimensionality from the lat
space r uh to a matrix D which is the
dimensional to the state space times R
of course if you want to of course this
depends on the full number of degrees of
freedom but if you want to reduce
further dimensionality you could
consider to restrict um this evaluation
only to let's say enable uh with some
enable of your actual submesh to make it
more the procedure more efficient and
fully independent respect to a number of
decreas of freedom but for Simplicity we
consider the full State space and so now
you can minimize you of course you have
to computer since your state space has
many physic can have physical fits so
like for example a number of C physical
fits like I don't know pressure and
velocity you have to uh take the alunar
with respect to that then you take the
AR Max with respect so you choose the
most influ influential latent variable
and then you you decide which are the
cells uh of your mesh
uh we are considering F volume method uh
cells of the mesh U which would
correspond to the to the magic points uh
in which this quantity this indicator
has its maximum
value
um okay so this for example uh you would
have this kind of uh sub meses that
evolve with Dynamics in the case of uh
compressible flow air foil and you can
see in black uh the magic points and in
uh gray the subesh around them and you
can see that more or less follows some
important features of the Dynamics from
type Step Zero to time step two
seconds uh we want also wanted to point
out another important characteristic of
the choice of our approximate which is
the possibility to use a local
formulation because now for example if
you have a uh uh it's time as parameter
as I show later you could for example
split the time inter in two and decide
to use one uh reduc uh one linear basis
for one sub one sub interval or the time
interval and one sub basis for the other
time interval um why this procedure is
still efficient because then you would
offline you could uh you would have two
ofen coders so one for subtime Interval
and then online you would just offline
you can just multiply the uh linear
bases and online you would just perform
this uh cheap uh change of bases between
uh P1 and P2 let's say the
dimensionality of your frequency space
uh of course this is very um simple and
maybe naive way to perform um um let say
uh the projection from one local linear
approximation to one other local linear
approximation in the literator there are
many uh work that that make uh this
procedure more rigorous and taking into
account other interface conditions but
this is a very simple way and we wanted
to point it out because could be uh used
with our approach if you really want to
do to use a local uh linear
approximation of your parameter
space and so the first test case I'm
going to consider is a compressible flow
air foil and the parameter we consider
here are time and the El mag number so
we choose the mar mass of our U gas such
that the speed of sound is equal to one
and in this way we can choose the macn
as parameter and set as the choice of
our um Inlet velocity from 2 to five in
the training range and from 1.8 to to
5.2 in our uh test range so just to give
you a grasp of the solution manifold we
are considering for the initial uh for
close to the initial time steps uh 0.2
seconds uh so the first and third
snapshot uh with mag number 5.2 and 1.8
these these are all in the extrapolation
regime so these are let's say the
extremal solutions but see it's very uh
big the solution manifold we want to
approximate and this is implemented this
obtain with the fin volume method in
open form with the Sonic form solver so
if you consider if you see if you look
into the Sonic form solver compared to
our implementation of the Nar manifold
method you see there are some
differences in fact the Sonic form
solver um uh first of all the fits we
are considering are the velocity that
field internal energy and the pressure
field and the Sonic form solare consider
a a predictor corrector numerical scheme
s also you consider a non orog corrector
because you when you have also as in
this case non orog meshes but instead in
the non real mindful method uh for each
evaluation of the residual we don't need
to uh to use this corrector scheme but
instead inside in know linear uh this re
optimization at each uh evaluation of
the residual so at each end time step
but also e e step of the optimization uh
we need to we can evaluate just the
residual in this way so without U
evaluate using the full uh scheme let's
say and also of course remember that we
only evaluate the residual on the sub
mesh okay so these are some uh predicted
solutions to for a qualitative
comparison and uh
this is what
um okay take some
times okay uh as you can see okay this
is the um full evolution of the sub mesh
and so in this case we have considered
for this test case uh 20 training uh
parameters as Mac number and five test
uh parameters and the test case I'm
showing you the sorry the snapshots I'm
showing you correspond to the m number
2.1 two4 as I mentioned in beginning I
consider as uh the dimensionality of
your linear projection so p is equals to
300 uh so we use three under rsbd mods
something that maybe you wouldn't do
with the reduc basis method and we
consider a lat dimensionality of r equal
to 4 these numbers are uh chosen only to
uh satisfy to achieve a good accuracy
with the wall uh reconstruction for the
wall reconstruction eror so in this case
we have used uh
1,200 adaptive tion collocation
nodes and they are updated not every
time step but only every 20 time steps
of course the choice of uh when to
update them can be uh maybe uh worked
out better with I don't know maybe a
posterior techniques and remember that
we comparison we're comparing the
computational cost with the open open
form solver and in this case if you
consider a meantime step we achieve not
much of a speed up less than true but
you see that 74 milliseconds for
evaluation for a single uh time Step At
The N manifold method is uh quite the
standard of also if you consider other
works in the literature the thing is
that now we compare with the full order
model made implemented in open form so
in very um uh high performance uh solver
for a very simple problem with just uh
32,000 cells but with metalic we also um
try to increase the time step
so that would incur in problems for the
C condition for the at the form level
that we could use a Time step also which
is four times um higher and this case we
do achieve a speed up of five for
evaluating the full Dynamics in this
simple test case and I show also some uh
result on the true relative error for
the local n manifold application so as I
told you we consider true time intervals
from 0 to 1.2 and from 0.6 to
2.5 and we consider two different um
rsvd modes for these true time intervals
and also out encoders and we compare
what are the errors uh with the uh use
of these uh two sub intervals or with
the use of one single subdomain so in
red one single of the main and in blue
two time intervals of course in uh with
the yellow line oh the we consider five
um trajectories are plotted all together
and the there they are divided by these
gray columns and in red in shaded red
there are the ex there is the
extrapolation regime which the solution
has very bad um
um errors and instead when uh in during
at inside the training regime inside the
training range it see a yellow vertical
line that is when uh you perform the
change of bases from one sub interval to
the other and the change is performed at
time
0.625 if I remember correctly and you
can see that in our case you cannot find
you cannot um you canot get better uh
approximations uh with the also with
choice of local uh linear manifolds uh
but maybe uh it's it's still good to
point out that you could do it in
practice
so the second test case is instead runs
around the Amed body so we consider the
compressible equations with the
turbulance model so thisas one equation
turbance model and the state we consider
in this case are the velocity uh the
pressure and also the viscosity so the
turbulence model is cut off in the end
when you consider the N linear manifold
method so the domain is like this and
you consider 200,000 cells and this test
case um has been uh first considered for
in model ruction well not in modelu
community but uh my collaborators have
been worked on on this test case
previously uh but they consider um a
station stationary test case so they
solve the equations with the simple
algorithm instead uh we try to predict
the transi Dynamics with the piso
algorithm in open form Bon solver in
open form so the parameter in this case
are time time from 0 to 0. seconds and
the Len angle of the am body uh we
consider true parametric instances true
parametric ranges the first parametric
range is from 15° to uh a bit more than
18 degrees and the other parametric
range is higher from 15 to uh
35 and we'll see what could go wrong
with this
methodology so these are the uh maybe
can share again the presentation
okay so these are again the evolution
this is again the evolution of the sub
mesh and in this case we consider only
five train parameters and four test
parameters and I'll show you the the
this is the predicted solution for slant
angle to this value and of course in
this case I repeat there consider pred
you want to predict velocity pressure
and you also predict the um the
viscosity and also in this case we
consider p equal to the so the number of
your rsvd modes are 300 and the
dimensionality of four uh again these
numbers are uh kept fixed also in this
case uh but just because we could
achieve a good accuracy with respect to
the extraction error so maybe they are
not optimal value you would choose maybe
from some parametric studies to find an
a lower maybe on a higher if you want to
achieve better accuracy for
example um so in in this case the magic
points are evaluated every uh 50 time
steps
and in this case you consider the
meantime step uh you would achieve a bit
of a speed up at least even if this is
still a very Co mesh in open F uh so you
would achieve at least a speed up of
five if consider only the mean time step
but also in this case we consider an
higher time step with respect to the
farm because we could do it at the
reduced level and in this case if you
consider the food Dynamics inutan a
speed up of
26 um of course maybe you don't see all
this a mesh because a big part of the
Dynamics so a big the higher the highest
values of the residual um are evaluated
below the HED body so the Stills um
around the Stills um there there are the
it's simly flow past the cylinder um
flow let's say and so the you can see
that residual uh so also the a mesh uh
follow this uh features below the amount
body
uh and this is also for the pressure for
some more quantitative
estimates uh you can see that the uh
pressure and velocity are quite little
approximated for this test case and
instead of the Ed viscosity you have
much worse approximations also because
it's more uh difficult to uh linearly um
approximate it in this case uh but of
course I want to to remind you that this
is a monol SBD so in a way the
pressure velocity and viscosity are
coupled in a single uh I
mode and of course this is still the uh
parametric domain range from uh 15° to
um a bit more than 18 degrees of this L
angle instead if you want consider this
parameter range from 15 to 35 uh there
will be some problems and this happens
not only for this implementation of the
manold method but also uh generally for
applications they consider also per
methods that consider um SVD as per step
and then a nonlinear out encoder and
then they maybe they learn the Dynamics
with another n this is because uh for
example if you see there are 13
parameters so the first plot at the top
there is the um so the the Aisa
corresponds to different parametric
instances of the um slant angle of the
am body so we have divided this interval
in uh 50
parts and um each uh each
parameter you can see uh 13 training uh
snapshots and the colors represent the
uh choice of rsvd modes used to evaluate
the Reconstruction error so this is the
train relative error and this is the
test relative error and you can see that
uh if you increase the number of mons
there is a parametric uh sub interval
for which you cannot achieve a good
accur even increas in the number of
months and this is very typical for a
lot of applications for which you need
maybe you think more data or maybe the
linear approximate is not good and
something you could try is to use
instead um local inter local
approximation so you may want to uh
let's say from a sort of clustering of
your param parameter space and decide
okay I def I divide my parameter space
into four parts and then apply SVD in
each of the two part hoping that the
reconstruction be better in that case
also um uh considering that you have
also many solution in that particular
subdomain and for some uh sub parametric
uh for some sub intervals of the uh
parametric space you obtain better
approximations uh but still not good
enough uh in the in some ranges of your
um in some intervals of your petric uh
domain and maybe in these cases uh other
approaches would be more um preferable
respect to the linear approximat maybe
you may want to try to use much bigger n
architectures such CNN if GDs of graph
Nar networks or more um or other
architectures and in this case so you
cannot use the methodology I presented
because you cannot use rsvd as propos
step but you can try to use another
approach we have developed before and
this uses um teacher student training so
you first
train uh very big um architecture for
example in this case for the for a n
linear conservation low problem you
train a convolutional out encoder from a
grid to a grid and then after training
it you can um train a smaller decoder
that you will use in your nonlinear
manful method and this decoder is made
by just two hidden layers and they it's
a very simple fit for n that is
evaluated from the latent coordinates to
just the uh submesh to the states of
your um training database but only
restricted to the sues so you do have
done a very smaller n to use for your
nonl manold
method and so I briefly summarized the
conclusion and possible pros and cons of
the methodology so uh what you have with
respect to data driven procedures is an
interpretable procedure so it's more
explicable as a procedure because at
each time step you are minimizing first
principle so uh so you're are minimizing
physical quantities and it's more
interpret respect to blackbox approaches
in which you plug in parameters and you
get
Solutions but at the same time you can
also as in data driven methods that use
for example out coders you can introduce
additional inductive biases so you can
add some equivariance properties in your
network or you could add also positivity
or physical quantities for example if
you have a density in your uh State
space you can um uh keep this constraint
for example with a r activation function
or also impose other constraints like a
weekly simpatic out encoder uh one
additional guarantee thetical guarantee
that that you can add with this
methology with respect to and with
respect to dat driven methodologies is
to the possibility to introduce also
structure preservation so um with this
formulation let's say uh you could also
try to implement additional constraint
because every time you just you don't
only evaluate an nwor but you also
minimize um with solving linearly Square
problem so you may want to try adding
energy conserving property or entropy
stable property for no conservation laws
um of course there are some cons and one
of them is the possible slow train time
maybe if the rsvd approximation arror is
good May me then this is not the case
because the uh training takes less than
one hour also with one single GPU but if
you consider for example CNS for is a
very simple problem like the one I shown
before for the nonlinear um conservation
law in a GD you can take you can take if
you consider convolution of the Cod even
more than five hours sometimes to
achieve a good
accuracy um so possible solutions are
represented by uh transfer learning or
um others by partition
approaches and of course another con
that you may require a large database of
snapshat to achieve higher accuracy it's
very difficult to achieve High um a very
good accuracy with the um uh outon
coders when you have a very uh difficult
uh PD model when your um solution
present a lot of small scale features
that you want to approximate and so this
is a very very difficult problem to
obtain more accurate and for our um
implementation small architectures
because you need them to solve for this
nonlinear Square problem and of course
there is the problem of um
hper reduction that sometime is not very
robust so you you may need want to work
on the robustness of the non linearly
Square methodology itself and including
the how hyper production is performed
and maybe approaches include uh
regularization for
example so these are the references our
works and I used as open source software
ITA volume uh mod reduction Library
developed form for open form and by PSY
and of course open F uh so thank you for
your attention and these are the uh
references I already uh shown you before
thank you thank you so much for the
wonderful talk Francisco uh very nice
let's have a Q&A sessions and if you
have questions please unmute yourself
and ask questions to Fran
schol while you guys are thinking about
it um let me ask um let me start to ask
some questions so let's okay
so um I mean you you you talked about
the teacher student Approach at in in
slide 26 but before that the majority of
times you spend um on you know the
specific kind of the hyper reductions
where it has a combination of the linear
map I'm assuming the Linea map is from
SVD type of yes exactly map okay so so
the the main idea is you apply the SVD
and reduce the dimension a bit and then
uh apply the the Deep comp computional
or the some sort of the neuronet
architecture to further reduce it yes
yes exactly the yeah the approach I
presented today is not on teacher
student training but on uh this kind of
nolinear approximate where in the end
yeah you have a no linear part with a no
linear uh 1D CNN layers in our case and
then a linear uh map from the frequency
space to the in this case the submesh
and it's can be it can be done
efficiently because you can restrict the
your um rsbd modes only on the Dos you
need for the subash right right so uh my
question regarding to that is as you you
know elaborate the motivation for the
nonlinear manif for reduc auto model you
know problem with the chog with decaying
slowly like for example consider the
pure convections right like one of the
purse is moving from left to the right
yes as you as we all
know um for that kind of problem because
the the solution snapshots are linearly
independent most of the U it's you got
to you need a lot of SVD modes right
yeah yeah and this approach since you're
combining you know linear SD linear map
with the neur map noria
mapping isn't it kind of limited to how
much the SVD can compress your original
data and if the the uh the the the data
is coming from Pure OBS for example then
you you pretty much like full almost
like the full space or full space
snapshots number of snapshots um so yeah
so can you comment com true
uh it's true but um but maybe often
times you don't need to I mean we
actually use a very high number of mods
I mean not very high but 3 is high and
usually you have this kogar of Decay
problem as totically so for some
applications you may still uh use a
limited number of um rsbd modes and
achieve a satisfactory accuracy also
because uh let's say the the interaction
case of uh um it's a like an extremal
case with respect to some applications
but some other examples of
um problems real problems where this
approach works also only data driven
problem so where only data driven
approach is tested uh can be found for
on the works of Stefania fresa and
manoni for their where they extendedly
tested their podl ROM uh technique and
then they've shown that also for some
electril physiology test cases uh you
may still with less than 300 modes
approximate Dynamics which is addaction
dominated so it really depends on the
accuracy you want to achieve and of
course when uh yeah when uh you get
problems like the one I've
shown at the end so in this case so when
you have uh also here I would say that
you have this problem so when uh you
cannot approximate well the solution
manifold with just lar modes then you
would really need to use um a nonlinear
Dimension reduction technique so yes
this this the approach I presented Works
uh in an intermediate regime let's say
where you can you when you need to use
uh more mods then what then the number
of mods you would use for a standard
ruce based methods uh but still um not
too many and so for you not to to
require nonlinear Dimension reduction
techniques great um my second question
is about the Adaptive hyper reductions
and there you are changing a list of
magic points every like 20 or 50
iterations yes um and once you change
the magic points
[Music]
um only the hyper reductions on the
linear map is you have to update it
online guess yes exactly but you don't
change anything on the the non Lineum
yes yes correct okay cool even there
like updating the linear map hyper
reduction informations that takes a some
Prett you know some computational time I
guess that's why but average the times
the cost is high uh yeah but in this
case we use only reduce over cocation so
um restricting the the mods to just the
submesh to a different submesh uh is
very efficient no I guess the the cost
really depends on the um number of um
iterations of your optimization scheme
with which uh optimization method that
you use to solve the nonlinearly square
problem of course this is uh I don't
know if in your experience but yeah it's
difficult to get under this value also
in our implementation maybe it's not as
efficient as uh the code which
implemented the numerical solvers of
open form since we we Blended let's say
uh python with the res validation in C++
inside open form and yeah maybe more
efficient implementation could be uh
performed yeah but sorry the efficient
implementation could help yeah maybe so
um yeah maybe implementing everything
C++ or uh yeah I cannot think of yeah
but maybe in your experience uh I mean
this is may not be much different with
respect to um your single iteration of
your um shallow masked out encoders so
maybe maybe maybe it's really the
comparison with the open form solvers In
This Very Co problems that yeah in some
sense it's
not sometimes you're you're not
comparing Apple to Apple I guess yeah
open form is a C++ and your and your
implementation is on what
python yeah we evaluate the residual
efficiently in C++ but the say the
network is on python so also the
optimization with the psy but py4 Pi
okay okay make it simple to test
different techniques
yes okay in that sense there's some room
for
improvements yes okay um I I have one
more questions if you if you have time
yeah sure I really kind of wanted to see
the more about the uh teacher student
approach so okay it correct like the
slide 26 but I thought that was really a
kind of um killer okay ker killer
approach um in
Nar manifold model um in general because
you do not have to rely on the that
linear map and it's it's and you can
fully um take advantage of the
expressibility of the you know
the neural network you the nonlinear map
neural network um yeah what kind of
speed up do you get um if you apply this
teacher student
training uh I remember that in those
cases um I still I remember um well
actually the grids are the ones I've
shown for hper production here so we
tested it on a nonlinear conservation
law and on the shallow water equations
yeah and the grid was I guess 60 by 6 so
it's very small problem solved in in
open form and also in this case uh I
guess we could not achieve a speed up I
mean we matched the mean time step for
the Nina conservation and we managed to
achieve a speed up of two for the
shallow water equations with the the
implementation of the teacher student
training Network and that case also we
computed also the Jacobian in a very um
efficient manner because we had only two
layer networks so we could
efficiently yeah oh
okay um and uh your full model was still
open form yeah it was still open form
yeah okay well um well thank you is
there any other
questions it's past 11
so well thank you so much Francesco
um it was wonderful um um and I learned
a lot so that is great um yeah if if
anyone has any questions for franisco
please reach out to him directly I'm
sure he's going to be happy to get any
questions from you guys yeah thank you
Francisco thank you bye have a good
day
bye Frisco